here we are in the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences under the
Oscar celebrating kung-fu films for the
40th anniversary of end of the Dragon
hosted by the Academy
you must all be incredibly psyched to be
witnessing this I mean this is kind of a
remarkable thing I would say probably
over the age of five everyone in the
world today knows who Bruce Lee is
everybody knows what kung fu is I've
seen people in the most remote corners
of the earth pulling kung-fu moves and
making Bruce Lee sounds I've been to
places like Sadr City and Baghdad and
rural Transylvania where people have
never seen an Asian person before and
little kids will run to me and say Bruce
Lee Bruce Lee when you watch The Matrix
and they take the plug out of the back
of Neos head and he says I know kung fu
we all know what that means but 45 years
ago just before all these posters that
you've seen and before this movie was
made no one outside of Chinatown or
martial art circles knew what kung fu
was and bruce lee was just another
martial arts teacher and out-of-work TV
actor whose show was canceled struggling
to make a living so what happened within
five years kung fu had exploded onto our
cultural landscape there was a TV series
there were disco songs bubble gum cards
there was a hanna-barbera cartoon on
Saturday morning Elvis did martial arts
on stage as one of our panelists here
said suddenly there was a kung-fu studio
in every small town in America parents
took their kids to martial arts on
Saturday morning like they were taken in
a baseball practice this all seems
really normal to us all now but this was
completely new and strange in 1973
kung fu films didn't just change the way
Hollywood worked how we made action
films how we perceived a market of
foreign films they also changed the way
this country looked at Asians in all
minorities in the 1960s we were still
making yellow face movies in Hollywood
Mickey Rooney played a caricature
Japanese and breakfast at tiffany's with
big fake buck teeth and a crazy accent
and Bruce Lee played a butler he was a
kick-ass kung fu Butler but still he was
relegated to the role of a Chinese
Butler Bruce Lee didn't invent the kung
fu film Chinese filmmakers were making
kung fu films since the silent
Phil Mara you could say that martial
arts films are to China and to Hong Kong
what westerns are to America and
Hollywood it's the genre that is
uniquely Chinese it in particularly
embodies Chinese ideals and culture
Bruce Lee I'm sure you all know was
actually a pretty big child star in Hong
Kong and the Hong Kong film industry but
it was his hope and dream to become a
global star in Hollywood and for those
of us in this room in this business I
think what is particularly interesting
is that Hollywood couldn't figure out
what to do with Bruce Lee
when Bruce Lee said he wanted to be a
bigger star than his friends James
Coburn and Steve McQueen they laughed at
him not to his face but but they laughed
at him Bruce Lee knew all these people
he knew people the very center of our
business he knew the biggest movie stars
in the world he knew film producers here
the head of a major studio Warner
Brothers I don't know if you know this
but Roman Polanski hired Bruce Lee to be
his fitness trainer these people
respected his talents they recognized
his charisma but there was a belief and
it's amazing because it's actually
memorialized in internal memos that
there was simply no way a person of
color could ever be a movie star a major
box-office draw that's not the most
remarkable thing about the story I think
the most remarkable thing is that Bruce
Lee despite this persevered endured and
found a way to show his talent to the
world the huge success of the Bruce Lee
films in Asia and then around the world
caused Hollywood to take notice and to
Hollywood's credit they did what
Hollywood does best they instantly
change course 180 degrees showed Bruce
their love and got ahead of the wave and
overnight and this is amazing between
1972 and 1973 nearly 20% of the film's
release in American theaters were
kung-fu films you know if you look at
the picture of the Warner Brothers
marketing department in 1973 it looks
like the cast of the Lawrence Welk Show
they it was like Opie and Harry at
Warner Brothers and they were tasked
with releasing these new movies that
came from Hong Kong that were in Chinese
that had guys jumping around and
screaming and hacking each other they
had no idea what to do with it in the
file in the marketing file I found a
whipping from the New York Times about a
Warner Brothers screening in Harlem of
five fingers of death during the film
someone came into the theater with a 22
pistol and tried to rob the concession
stand and five members of the audience
incredibly amped up after seeing their
first kung fu film ran out beat the guy
up unarmed took his gun away from him
and held him until the police arrived
though the power of kung fu' the the
best thing the punch line for me is the
warners brothers marketing department
put a note in the clipping saying what
do we do with this should we were should
we release a press release this is the
press release should we should we
calling the press about this Bruce Lee
became an inspiration not just to me but
to generations of young minority actors
musicians filmmakers martial artists not
just because of his physical mastery but
because of his powerful defiance his
innate dignity his grace and his passion
Bruce Lee refused to be belittled he
refused to be marginalized and he
refused to be dismissed he commanded our
attention he commanded the frame he
demanded respect he had a power and
magnetism that few people have ever had
kung fu films changed America and they
changed the world so I want to say thank
you Bruce Lee thank you the producers of
Enter the Dragon thank you the Hong Kong
film industry and Warner Brothers all
the kung fu practitioners who toil and
obscurity and suffered making these
films and I want to thank the Academy
for preserving these posters from this
very special moment in our history thank
you thank you for coming today